[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de Franz 24 en América Latina
como en el resto del mundo son las
superproducciones estadounidenses y sus
Héroes fantásticos las que lideran las
carteleras desde hace unas semanas
empezando con la versión en live action
del clásico de 1999 de Disney La
Sirenita desde su estreno el 25 de mayo
logró recaudar casi 200 millones de
dólares a nivel internacional a pesar de
las críticas y de los ataques racistas
que ha desatado desde el anuncio en 2019
de que sería protagonizada por la actriz
afro americana
la cinta de Rob Marshall sufre ahora de
lo que se llama el review bombín o
bombardeo de reseñas una estrategia de
manipulación de los sistemas de
clasificación de películas en línea
inundandolos de puntuaciones bajas y
comentarios negativos páginas como imdb
en Estados Unidos o alucina en Francia
tuvieron que colocar advertencias
explicando que la distribución inusual
de las puntuaciones de esta película
deben Llamar a la prudencia y animando
el público a formarse su propia opinión
[Música]
otro éxito taquillero esta vez con
buenas reseñas de parte tonto de la
crítica como del público es el tercer y
último volumen de la saga Marvel
Guardianes de la galaxia recaudó más de
700 millones de dólares en la taquilla
mundial desde su estreno a principios de
mayo este éxito se debe al equilibrio
que al director y guionista James
mantiene entre el sentido de humor de
sus peculiares personajes sus
espectaculares escenas de acción y sus
impactantes momentos de emoción una
mítica ronda Sonora completa la ecuación
y ayuda a entender como los Guardianes
de la galaxia logró forjarse tantas
singularidad dentro del inmenso Universo
de los cómics Marvel
[Música]
[Aplausos]
recién estrenada se espera que otra
película Marvel spider-man a través del
Spider verso también alcance récords
Esta secuela es una de las cintas de
animación más largas de la historia del
cine con más de dos horas y ya siguió
aclamada por su creatividad visual cada
uno de los seis mundos en donde navega
el adolescente araña está representado
con estilos de dibujo y animación
diferentes Incluso el célebre cineasta
mexicano Guillermo del Toro se declaró
fan de esta película miramos el
[Música]
siempre quieren decirme cómo debe ser mi
historia
voy a hacerlo
[Música]
atención todo
nos quedamos en Hollywood para hablar de
la huelga de los guionistas que cumple
su primer mes el 2 de mayo el sindicato
de guionistas de Estados Unidos inició
un paro laboral tras la ruptura de las
negociaciones con los representantes de
los estudios cadenas de televisión y
plataformas de streaming algunas
producciones se están retrasando y
viéndose muy afectadas por este paro los
guionistas exigen mejores condiciones y
hasta el momento no parece haber una
salida pero pueden contar con el apoyo
de muchos profesionales del cine
creo que los guionistas no están
pidiendo nada que no debieran creo que
cada vez que los que están por debajo de
la línea dicen que necesitamos ser
reconocidos por lo que hacemos Es que
necesitamos ser lo sabes y estamos con
ellos no están pidiendo nada más que
poder vivir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo empieza en la página ya sabes y yo
les apoyo de verdad sin un ápice de duda
ellos son los que inician todos los
proyectos
sin sus historias sin sus palabras no
tenemos nada que decir podríamos hacer
mímica ya sabes mímica podríamos hacer
de todo
Así que ya sabes no es tan interesante
vamos a mirar ahora a la primera
exposición en 10 años en Argentina de
una de las artistas conceptuales más
destacadas del país la muestra se llama
Mario oren suns el fluir del pensamiento
del nombre de esta artista plástica
radicada en Francia y pone en diálogo
obras de épocas diferentes para
presentar a esta artista plural y su
crítica mordas a las relaciones de poder
y a la opresión de la mujer en la
sociedad la exposición se puede ver en
el muntref centro de arte contemporáneo
en Argentina hasta el 25 de Julio
nuestro corresponsal en Argentina
natalio cosoy coversó con ella
te voy a mostrar una de las últimas
obras que se llama lo justo y esencial
[Música]
es esta esta serie de sobre tela y que
tiene que ver con la escultura donde no
hay nada más que el pleno y el vacío y
que puede se puede jugar de diferente
formas Ese es para mí es el
hilo de Unión es la el pensamiento desde
el momento que estos lo justo y esencial
cuando sacamos todo y aquellos son los
dominantes que eran los justos pero no
esencial
siempre hago cambios en la obra no me
gusta la repetición yo me interesa
Probar con nuevos materiales con nuevas
formas Pero
para repetirme no me interesa es decir
yo ya hago una cosa y veo no no es el
comercio el que me interesa a mí es el
dejar algo para los otros es el provocar
una reflexión
provocar un encuentro
[Música]
hablemos ahora de una escuela francesa
que quiere cambiar la industria de la
moda desde el interior la casa 93 megay
del nombre del barrio popular donde está
ubicada forma gratuitamente a una docena
de jóvenes bajo la dirección de
conocidos diseñadores según sus
directora dentro de Los criterios que
los candidatos deben cumplir para ser
seleccionados figura tener un gran
corazón para una moda más responsable
socialmente ampliamos en este informe
en medio de las telas de las bobinas de
hilo y de los maniquíes 13 estudiantes
escuchan con mucha atención como estos
diseñadores de moda analizan su trabajo
El ejercicio del día reinterpretar
prendas Valentino para adaptarlas a la
vida cotidiana y aprender a hacer ropa
que durará
creo que hemos perdido completamente la
noción de hacer la ropa que llevamos
porque ahora está la alta costura por un
lado y la moda rápida por otro pero para
hacer ropa que dure como la nuestra 30
40 o 50 años que la gente vuelva a
comprar ahora tenemos que enseñarles a
hacer ropa de nuevo Así que eso es lo
que estamos haciendo la escuela casa 93
migay se destaca por su conciencia
ecológica pero también por sus valores
sociales su formación está abierta
jóvenes de 18 a 25 años sin exigencia de
diploma y sobre todo de forma gratuita
un criterio esencial para Sofía que no
tenía los recursos económicos para
estudiar moda en otro lugar
elegí esta escuela de moda porque tiene
una metodología de trabajo diferente a
las demás
en el sentido de que se aprende
directamente sobre el terreno se aprende
directamente en el trabajo y por lo
tanto a mí me ayuda a asimilar mejor las
cosas
la aventura comenzó hace 18 años en Río
de Janeiro donde nadin González abrió
dos pequeñas escuelas de moda en las
favelas de vuelta a Francia en 2017 su
proyecto creció en los suburbios de
París y llegó finalmente al sur del país
en Tulum pero no en cualquier barrio
del umbral de la pobreza Así que
pensamos que aquí podríamos encontrar
jóvenes que encajaran bien con nuestro
grupo objetivo
jóvenes de 18 a 25 años que están en una
situación complicada desde el punto de
vista financiero psicológico etcétera es
decir no pueden permitirse ir a una
escuela de moda no pueden permitírselo o
creen que no tienen lo que hay que tener
para entrar en esta escuela
la casa 93 aspira a cambiar desde el
interior una industria que enfrenta
retos de diversificación y de
sostenibilidad dando una oportunidad a
jóvenes creadores de barrios populares
franceses que serán los diseñadores de
moda del mañana
llegó la hora de nuestra sección
dedicada a la música y a los estrenos de
esos últimos días empezando con
el primer álbum de la bomba de Rocky
estadounidense foo Fighters estrena
desde que murió Taylor o Kings el
baterista que grabó ocho discos de
estudio con el grupo falleció el 25 de
marzo de 2022 en Bogotá a los 50 años
este nuevo álbum está dedicado a esta
pérdida y a la lucha de los integrantes
de foo Fighters contra el dolor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mucho antes
Entonces el miércoles la cantautora
veracruzana Silvana Estrada lanzó
milagro y desastre una canción donde
quiso reivindicar todas las caras del
amor incluso del amor que duele cuando
acaba la artista mexicana se prepara
para una gira en Europa con fechas en
Londres Berlín Madrid y París entre
otras
[Música]
para nunca adore
en mí
[Música]
y del lado de Nigeria la súper estrella
de la música afro rema dio a conocer el
videoclip de su tema uno de los éxitos
presentes en la revisión de su primer
álbum raiden que consagró al cantante
nigeriano de tan solo 23 años conocido
en el mundo entero por su hitdown pero
cuyos otros temas valen totalmente la
pena
[Música]
Nos despedimos con otra talentosa joven
artista nigeriana airestar de 20 años y
su tema savility Gracias a ustedes por
su confianza y sigan con nosotros hay
más cultura en Franz 24 y 24.com
[Música]
por tiempo el día